le symbole de l'échec industriel voici
les mots des ex-salariés de weir poule à
amiens qui s'estime aujourd'hui
abandonnée par emmanuel macron à
l'occasion de la visite du chef de
l'état dans le département de la somme
le député et les fit françois ruffin aux
côtés d'une cinquantaine d'anciens
salariés invite le président à revenir
sur le site quatre ans après ses
promesses sur le parking du 8 pool
durant sa campagne présidentielle en
pendant la campagne manuel mâcon est
venu sur ce parking il y en a fait un
symbole un symbole de l'industrie un
symbole de son lien au monde ouvrier et
prom était à l'époque l'avenir
industriel est garanti
quatre ans plus tard qu'est ce qu'on a
sur les 286 salariés il reste 3 voilà ce
que ça donne quand l'état a investi 15
millions d'euros et quand emmanuel
macron souhaitait place trois fois avec
ta ta promesse tous les emplois seront
repris
ça sera un cluster formidable et ainsi
de suite il faut pas que ça passe
inaperçu cette histoire il faut que
faire quoi pascal emmanuel macron on a
lui même fait le symbole le symbole de
son lien avec le monde ouvrier qui
aujourd'hui des faits revenu ensuite en
emmanuel macron avait donné rendez vous
l'année suivante aux salariés en colère
deux ans plus tard sans aucune autre
visite du président français
les ex salariés se sentent condamnées et
laissées à leur propre sort
aujourd'hui ce chômage donc je suis chez
paulo
j'en veux énormément parce que c'était
des promesses et c'est gratuit je crois
c'est des promesses emmanuel macron est
revenu sur le site du temps de w est
donc encore des promesses
une fois et les revenus du temps de
dzeko agencement encore avec des
promesses et puis finalement les
promesses n'ont pas abouti donc on se
retrouve tous sur parquet ça fait mal au
coeur quoi puisque 51 ans 51 aujourd'hui
pour retrouver du travail s'il va pas
être facile
ce bet5 c3 grisons après trois
tentatives de reprise et plus de 280
salariés licenciés officiellement pour
motif économique
françois ruffin défend un
protectionnisme national industrielle ya
la question de ses salariés 6 mai il ya
la question de je le redis de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut produire
pourquoi on accepte de plus avoir une
seule usine de lave linge dans tout le
pays alors que la petite suisse en a
deux on est incapable d'avoir des
médicaments on est incapable d'avoir des
masques on est incapable de d'avoir deux
de produire du gel hydro alcoolique il
faut qu'on trouve on réinvente et on
sait pas faire tout ce savoir faire part
à l'autre bout du monde parce que c'est
des gens qui avaient dû savoir-faire
aussi et on se retrouve à poil et bien
moi je pense qu'il faut protéger notre
pays
le 31 mars dernier le tribunal de
commerce d'amiens avait validé le projet
de reprise partielle d'âge etc aux
agencements ndt dernier repreneur en
date par l'entreprise moby décor au
total 45 salariés ont été licenciés
principalement des ex whirpool un
troisième plan social en trois ans